recent Google research shows cyber
thieves have made at least 25 million
dollars from ransomware in the last two
years and this is expected to grow to
protect ourselves and our customers from
this and other types of malware we've
built multiple layers of protection most
of which are automated and available to
our customers by default first our
global visibility and the malicious
sites and content makes detection highly
effective if you're a gmail user we
prevent thousands of malicious
attachments from ever reaching inboxes
if something does reach your Inbox
Google Safe Browsing and our Chrome
browser protects users by identifying
dangerous links in email and showing
warnings if users click on them this
stops access to any web sites which are
known to distribute malware if you've
ever been blocked from a site like this
you've experienced Safe Browsing at work
every minute of the day we find and
label another malware site and warned
users have suspected malware hundreds of
times in Google Drive all files undergo
a malware scan prior to any download or
sharing drive also stores files in
non-executable formats which prevent
ransomware from propagating our Chrome
operating system continually updates
automatically ensuring it's highly
resistant to malware compromised
applications our sandbox to prevent harm
to the host machine often these features
remove any need for anti-malware or
antivirus software and at the mobile
device level every single day we check
the health of over 400 million Android
devices and scan over 6 billion mobile
applications downloaded to Android
phones to make sure they're not infected
Safe Browsing protects over 2 billion
mobile phones laptops tablets and other
devices which use Google software to
find out more about how google cloud can
help protect you from major cyber
threats
contact us at google.com slash cloud
slash security
you